it's great to be joined today by Ken
Jennings who holds the record for
consecutive Jeopardy wins at 74 games
he's earned over four million dollars on
game shows and is now an author whose
latest book is called planet funny how
comedy took over our culture ken I have
so many things to ask you about
different things and and it's just
really great to talk to you so thank you
for taking the time that's a pleasure
thanks for having me so let's start with
a little bit of Jeopardy stuff so just
to let's get see if we can clarify some
of the very common misperceptions that
people might have about how the game
works you are not liable to be asked
about literally anything on a particular
episode the guests the contestants have
a sense of the topics that will be part
of a particular show is that correct
that is a very common misconception for
some reason I have no idea why people
think that but I think vast swathes of
America assume that the contestants know
what the categories are going to be on
Jeopardy on a given night and that's not
true the contestants don't see those
categories until the same time the home
viewers do and Alec says let's see what
the categories are nuclear physics
gangster rap and that's the first time
we've seen them now have you gotten any
study material even without having a
delineation of the categories or do you
get nothing it's just show up and
whatever's in your head is what what
you're going to have to go on absolutely
nothing I mean if you've been watching
the show for 35 years like many people
have you have some sense of the kinds of
things
jeopardy will ask the style of the
questions you know there's gonna be
presidents and world capitals there's
kind of a cannon but no you have no idea
going in on that day whether it's going
to be hockey or country music or the
franco-prussian war okay how much of
success on the game show depends on one
the the facts you have in your head
versus two the right timing for when you
buzz in I mean you can't win without
both you know somebody without the facts
has zero chance to win but the thing is
the show has a very tough audition
process like everybody there had to pass
a very difficult simulation of a
Jeopardy game so on any given night all
three of the players I'm Oh
to the players know most of the answers
most of the time and because of that it
really does come down to in practice it
turns out to be like 8020 buzzer because
everybody knows all the answers and it's
just who can get in first and is there a
downside to so I guess what what is the
secret to the buzzer timing because you
can't you can't buzz in too early either
right right often on the show you'll see
somebody just earner wailing away on
their buzzer and you think oh that poor
guy has things not working the fix is in
do they not like Canadians what's going
on and in fact what happens is you can't
just buzz whenever you know it you have
to wait for Alex to finish reading the
question or the clue and then at that
point some assistant somewhere flips a
switch and activates all the buzzer and
then your buzzers live if you buzz in
before that point you actually get
locked out for a fraction of a second so
when you see somebody doing this what
you're seeing is somebody who got so
adrenalin up they buzz too early you
have to be in this very zen state where
you hear Alex's voice died away you wait
like a brief syllable length pause and
then you just jam your thumb on that
thing as if your life depended on it
okay so as the wings start racking up
and I remember I don't know and remember
exactly how old I was when this was
going on but I do remember it as the
winds start racking up what is the first
sign or are there signs that the
producers are starting to say you know
that this we never really accounted for
a streak that was this long this maybe
isn't how the game is is designed to go
and then part two of the question is is
there a point at which the streak takes
on a life of its own and then it becomes
a really great thing for the show that's
exactly what happened this was a very
recent rule change about a year after I
auditioned when they called me to say
hey we have a slot in three weeks they
said oh hey we've got this new rule
change contestants are no longer going
to get retired forcibly after five games
it used to be kind of a Logan's Run
thing where you won five games they gave
you a car and the next night they had
all new people right and I was and I was
like oh well thanks for letting me know
but that is very unlikely to affect me
and sure enough that's what happened it
did the change had just happened a month
a few months ago I'm sure they kind of
wanted the excitement of a long streak
but maybe they were thinking 7 or 9
games it was a long streak I don't think
they were planning on six months
and the contestants don't get that you
don't get to chat with the producers
there's very strict security you know
because of the laws on the on the
federal books about rigging game shows
you don't get anytime face time with
anybody who might know the answer is not
Alex not the producers nobody who
actually runs the show so there were a
few conference calls where they wanted
me to do publicity where I could tell
they were a little nervous you know and
and I've since heard retro actively yes
behind the scenes they were terrified
what if I had just broken jeopardy after
30 years and at one point on one of
these calls I asked at what point do you
just like you know forcibly retire me at
what point do i dis Alexei alright Ken
we've decided you've been on long enough
and there's a long pause and they say
our rule say a contestant plays he'll he
or she loses right and and they had so
they had 48 I think shows of me in the
can before any of them started to air so
they've got months of me and they have
no way of knowing if people are gonna
hate it or like it right and when they
finally start at the area did kind of
organically turn into a thing Jeffery
didn't promote it but people just
started saying hey this guy's been on
for like two weeks you got to watch this
and then SportsCenter started covering
it and it turned into a thing and it
turned out to be very good for their
ratings but they didn't know that going
in now if they were determined to get
you off the show there are probably ways
that they could do it that wouldn't
violate sort of the structure or the
rules right like maybe I don't know
really figuring out what your unlikely
to know much about and stacking those
categories or I guess I'm just imagining
being a producer like if they said we've
got to get this guy off there's probably
ways they could do it without breaking
the rules or the law though they have as
long as they follow the guidelines that
they've given to all contestants and if
they you know generally follow they can
pretty much do what they want but that's
what they're independent there's like an
agency that little monitor stuff for
them and that's where they'll get told
just follow your guidelines and don't do
anything specific anyone contested but
in their case their practice was to
select all the material blindly and
randomly so it actually would have
violated their own practices interesting
to give like anti-can questions whatever
those are
and but there were a few things they
could do and they were smart changes
they made
on the playing field they came back from
hiatus and they had changed their daily
schedule of contestant warm-ups so that
the the new contestants the challengers
got much more time to practice on the
stage with the buzzer the practices were
rehearsals were much more similar to the
actual show interesting and that's what
the games did get a lot closer and I
felt very proud of that it was like they
had you know it's like widening the the
lane in the NBA for Wilt Chamberlain or
whatever you know right had to change
the rules for me that is fascinating so
now I guess we can start getting into
what you're doing now and I think a good
lead-in to that will be correct me if
I'm wrong but the perception I had of
how you started to be sort of
caricatured in media that reported on
the streak was as the sort of very
wholesome character and I don't know if
that was on the basis like of of
religion or your physical appearance or
your demeanor or what do you agree that
that's kind of like the character that
was built up about you independently of
like whether it's accurate or not was
that sort of the Ken Jennings of the
media yeah I think so I'm kind of an OB
looking guy I was a Mormon guy who I'm a
Mormon guy who was living in Salt Lake
City Utah at the time and one thing
everybody on Jeopardy generally seems
kind of bland and milquetoast you can't
really there's no way to create a
character of someone based on their
jeopardy appearances because most people
are the format does not lend itself to
any kind of showboating or character
work
so yeah insofar as people were writing
about me they were saying you know this
wholesome guy from Utah but I actually
was like a suburban dad from from deeply
Mormon Utah that was not too far off so
then I saw that when you now have you
have a Twitter account now I don't know
when it when it started but you have a
Twitter account and you also write and
on the Twitter account you sometimes do
make political statements or or make
comments about politics and it seems
like in when I look at the comments
people are like extra put off in a sense
if it seems like their politics don't
align with yours and I don't know why
like is the idea that because you you
were on Jeopardy and they saw you as
this very sort of narrow
question-answering guy that it's not
okay all of a sudden for you to have
political opinions or like are you
surprised by some of the feedback you
get when you make political posts on
Twitter I mean well
just part of Twitter is you'll have
athletes or comedians or whatever who
are like we shouldn't be separating kids
from their parents and you know every
conservative will be like stick to
comedy or stick to baseball or whatever
you know that's that's just the
phenomenon of public life we you know
you should have no opinions once you
decide to play baseball or whatever and
it's probably intensified in my case
just because Jeopardy's audience friends
old yeah so you have a lot of baby
boomers you have a lot of kind of
graying America including a lot of red
state Americans watching the show and
I'm sure some of them are like he seemed
so nice when he was on Jeopardy with
Alex but now look what he's saying about
our president you know so I think there
is some of that so let's talk a little
bit about comedy because your book
planet funny how comedy took over our
culture makes a lot of very interesting
analyses of what's going on within the
comedy world and I feel like lately
especially comedy has become such a way
to satirize politics and and sometimes
it's almost become comedy writers have
had a pretty tough job lately because
even their wildest and wackiest ideas
don't actually seem that much further
than what we're experiencing in the real
world what's your sense of the way in
which comedy and satire has worked its
way even into sort of the most serious
elements of society is that a good thing
or is that something that can make
serious issues seem not serious that
tire is very old you know the plays of
Aristophanes thousands of years ago are
full of sat there it's certainly not a
new idea to make jokes about the
government and we're not even in the
first age where people were like whoa
satire is dead things are too crazy um
you can find quotes of people Tom Lehrer
said that about Watergate in Vietnam you
know that you can't be a satirist in the
era of water day in Vietnam the stuffs
do crazy and I remember Conan O'Brien
saying that at the height of the the
Bill Clinton kind of star affair you
know like there's sex jokes on page one
how do we do how do we do comedy now and
what is unprecedented now is I think
kind of the blurring of the line between
politics between actual policy and
current events and what the comedians
are saying you have a generation of kids
getting their news from comedy show
and that has some unintended
consequences actually there's some
research showing that you know Jon
Stewart fans who got their news from The
Daily Show you know I think he was
trying to he was a passionate man trying
to inspire people to take a point of
view and point out problems in the world
using humor and instead what happened is
he made a generation of kids pretty
cynical people who watch that show were
very convinced that the media and
politics were broken and their response
from it was to disengage it did not help
voting rates it did not help political
activism yeah I mean I guess the one
thing it did do is they were they were
quite informed in other words there were
a number of interesting polls which
showed that they did seem to be closely
aligned with the facts to a greater
degree than somebody who was primarily
consuming actual serious news you're
bringing up sort of the second layer
effect which is well what did they do
with that information and sadly the
voting rates of that demographic are not
impressively high as you're pointing out
yeah it just seems like today when
there's such an abundance of satire we
can see that it's kind of impotent you
know we see a hilarious joke about Trump
online or you know some epic John Oliver
takedown and we're like yeah I'm gonna
retweet this I've done my part it turns
out that actually does nothing
you know activism might work voting
might work but really satire often is a
way for people to kind of blow off steam
and feel like they've helped which
actually benefits those in power it's
the it becomes a yeah a steam vent that
avoids actual pressure building up I'm
curious what you think about I mean I'm
trying to figure out the right way to
set this up but there's certainly ones
like right now we're in the middle of
this n-word controversy with Omarosa and
so on and so forth the use of the n-word
is an example for us is seen very
differently if it is satirical versus
not satirical and there are very
divergent views about that and even in
satire can anybody use the word or can
only some people use the word what's
your sense more generally about the idea
that discriminatory offensive or
prejudicial things that would not be
acceptable outside of satire become
acceptable merely by calling them comedy
like is that a good thing is it problem
matic in some ways I think we used to
give comedians a pretty wide carve-out
you know they were kind of a special
protected class we needed our court
jesters and so it pretty much was to get
out of jail card to be like oh that was
just a joke right so you'd have you have
comedians make if he jokes about race or
class or war or whatever taboo topics
and they could say oh that's just a joke
and I'm kind of glad we've reached the
end of that because it's kind of a
cop-out right I mean of course it's a
joke but it's an utterance it's out
there in the air like any other it
affects listeners like any other and I
think it's fair to ask follow-up
questions like okay Roseanne you said
you were joking boom what does that mean
to compare an african-american woman to
an eight like what did you think the
consequences of that are what might the
real-world implications of that be
because this is another area where there
is good research if you give a set of
subjects discriminatory jokes
disparagement humor they call it and
then you compare it to people who
received non-disparagement humor you
know light banal jokes and a third group
that received discriminatory material
that was not in humor form the first
group gets affected the most that's the
thing that will affect behavior
something about humor couching a
difficult idea or controversial idea it
within a joke allows it to seep into our
brains and maybe subconsciously affect
the way we act people who listen to that
material is more likely to react in a
discriminatory way when given follow-up
tasks so I think it's not a joke at all
and I'm I'm glad you know I don't want
to say it's the thought police now
because there is no such thing but I'm
glad we're examining jokes more to see
what their real-world impact might be
the book is fascinating it's called
planet funny how comedy took over our
culture we've been speaking with the
book's author Ken Jennings Ken really
great talking to you today oh it's a
pleasure thanks for having me didn't